Big milestone for the David Pakman show achieved yesterday. We reached
500,000 subscribers
on our YouTube channel youtube.com/thedavidpakmanshow. And what I like to do whenever we reach a big milestone on the YouTube
channel is look back at old analytics; and I went back and looked at the first month we were on YouTube..
Okay, Pat was in kindergarten at the time... We had
721 views that month. Okay,I didn't mean to miss speak. I'm not saying we had 721 viewers,
I'm not saying we had 721 views per day. The first month
we were on YouTube, the entire month we ended up with
721 views and four subscribers,
three of which were probably
accounts my mom made. Okay, those are the right numbers. In July of 2018, last month
we added
16,000 subscribers. We had 16,000 new subscribers just last July and more than 8.1
million views and it happened
rolling over from
499 thousand 999
subscribers to the miraculous
majestic and
towering number of
500,000 views. I was sitting there watching it,
Pat was sitting there watching it and it was a moment to behold and
This is huge for us
Thanks to everyone of the 500 thousand. Now
it's even more  - we're already up to like 500,150  or something like that
so onward and upward to 1 million; more content, more miniseries, more long-form pieces, interviews everything. But I do want to say -
It's really not the subscribers that matter
It's the views. You could have a million subscribers
and no views and that's where our focus continues to be. People may not know this but of
our views only 30% come from subscribers; 70% of our entire channel views are from non
subscribers who either see our video recommended when watching something else or make a search for something like
"Trump embarrasses himself hugely in front of the Japanese Prime Minister" and maybe our video comes up
So subscriber milestone -very important, but onward and upward and continuing.
Pat: Yeah, our channel is ranked 6000 in video views
Which doesn't sound that impressive
until you compare it to like the tens of millions of YouTube channels out there and then it sounds pretty good.
David: And then if you watch on TV or listen on the radio or to the podcast then this has nothing to do with any of
your experience with the show
So in that sense if you're not a YouTube viewer
I apologize for the interruption and we're gonna take a quick break and then get back to the meat of the programming
But if you are part of our success on YouTube, thank you. I really do appreciate it.
Send your messages of congratulations or of trolling and
predictions that this is almost the end for the show,
which people do every day, on Twitter at D Pakman or to the show on Twitter at David Pakman show.